en république islamique d'iran on vote
le plus loin dans des mosquées
nous sommes ici à la mosquée jawad au
coeur de téhéran
la police veille au bon déroulement du
scrutin un peu partout
le portrait de l'ayatollah ali khamenei
le guide suprême de la république
islamique d'iran
la plupart de ses électeurs
appartiennent au camp conservateur ils
se sont levés de bonne heure beaucoup
d'entre votre rang pour l'ultra
conservateur ebrahim raïssi le grand
favori du scrutin
l'actuel chef du pouvoir judiciaire
iranien est un proche du guide suprême
[Musique]
l'ex-président et abdou diouf économique
a mis en place des religions
des centristes on trees are actually
selon de nombreux critiques il s'agit
d'un scrutin verrouillé taillé sur
mesure pour permettre la victoire
électorale
ebrahim raïssi en effet un grand nombre
de candidatures ont été invalidés par le
conseil des gardiens de la constitution
une instance proche du guide suprême
chargée de valider les candidatures 600
personnes s'étaient portées candidates à
l'élection à la présidence seulement 7
ont été retenus parmi ces sept retenus
cinq conservateurs et seulement deux
modérés
quasiment inconnu de l'électorat
conséquence une bonne partie de
l'électorat pourrait décider de
boycotter le scrutin le taux de
participation constitue l'un des enjeux
majeurs de cette élection